anche quando siamo assorti in altro il
nostro corpo reagisce agli stimoli
esterni
il lasciarsi influenzare contaminare e
inconscio quando per esempio vediamo
sbadigliare qualcuno quante volte di
seguito abbiamo sbagliato anche noi
sbadigliare uno dei comportamenti più
contagiosi osservati indica che chi
sbadiglia si sta identificando con il
contesto che lo circonda
si crea una connessione senza rendersene
conto
quando ero piccola avevo l'abitudine di
camminare con un piede storto rivolto
verso l'interno
nulla di grave era solo un vizio di
postura succede a molti bambini e primi
anni di vita mia madre mi portò da un
medico che le suggerì di farmi
frequentare un corso di danza classica
la camminata di un danzatore classico è
più o meno così dopo lunghi anni di
esercizi che favoriscono l'extra
notazione delle anche si tende ad avere
la cosiddetta camminata a papera
quindi io dopo qualche anno di danza
anziché camminare con un solo piede
storto verso l'interno tendeva ad avere
entrambi i piedi storti ma verso
l'esterno
poi ho rinunciato a camminare con i
piedi dritti se analizziamo gli esercizi
che un danzatore classico fa lezione ci
rendiamo conto che il corpo per come è
strutturato viene forzato a fare cose
che non sono del tutto naturali per
esempio piegare la colonna vertebrale in
questo modo ammirate la mia
presentazione olografica per non parlare
della rotazione esterna degli arti
inferiori
l'elasticità del piede o camminare sulle
punte esercitando le sensibilità dei
tendini per favorire un maggiore
equilibrio gli anni che ho dedicato alla
danza classica sono stati tanti e ci
sono voluti parecchi sacrifici per poter
acquisire tutti quei requisiti tecnici
che servono per poterti definire
danzatore classico studiavo con impegno
e dedizione ma mancava una parte
importante me stessa e come vedevo e
vivevo ciò che mi circondava
nel 2001 è avvenuta la mia rinascita
tramite un audizione fu scelta per far
parte di una compagnia di danza
contemporanea in occasione di uno
spettacolo la danza contemporanea nasce
con l'obiettivo di allontanare la
rigidità e la formalità dei canoni
classici del balletto per poter quindi
orientarsi su una danza libera priva di
regole codificate e costrizioni tramite
gesti figure forme si cerca di dare voce
alle emozioni alle sensazioni la danza
contemporanea mi affascina da subito e
mi innamorai della possibilità di poter
coinvolgermi in prima persona di poter
trovare ricercare dentro me i limiti e
le difficoltà che possedevo e trovare un
modo per abbatterli trovando una strada
alternativa innamorai di come la
creatività la fantasia potessero fare la
differenza e potessero far diventare
danza qualsiasi cosa io volessi ero
felice di scoprirmi e mettermi in gioco
quel che ne fa ho creato una compagnia
di danza contemporanea la compagnia
venera crea l'obiettivo del mio lavoro
con la compagnia oltre a rispettare
determinati criteri tecnici rappresenta
l'essenza di un lavoro di osservazione
ed introspezione ciò che ci circonda si
fonde con ciò che siamo e importante
cercare dettagli da cattura dell'esterno
osservare ad ascoltarci
cosa ci provoca vedere o sentire
qualcosa che sta accadendo intorno a noi
e fermarci anche su piccoli dettagli
sul colore di una maglia di un ragazzo
ferma di un semaforo
oppure su espressione arrabbiata di un
signore che scuotendo le mani discute
con un anziano o semplicemente un odore
un odore che ci può far tornare indietro
nel tempo ad un momento vissuto ad un
emozione provata prendo tutto ciò
rielaboro dentro me osservo la mia
reazione interiore e nel mio caso la
rende viva questa unione con dei
movimenti del corpo per agevolare questo
lavoro di stimoli di osservazione
qualche giorno qualche volta incontri
miliari al di fuori una fra danza in una
cava abbandonata per esempio o al mare o
al parco e per esempio al parco osservo
le foglie che si muovono con il vento un
ragazzo che parla al cellulare in tasca
ed inizia a correre
oppure immagino di spolverare un
appartamento con tutto il corpo polvere
una mensola in alto esposto il tappeto
con un piede e spolvero sotto pulisco
dei vetri apro l'imposta contagio e
richiudo prendo un secchio lo posso
prendo il mocio chiudo l'acqua prendo il
secchio al peposo giu infilo il motion
plus ruoto lo sposto sul pavimento e
iniziò a passare lo straccio e
un'influenza mi lascio contaminare e
allo stesso modo il diverta contamina
degli altri per vedere quel che accade e
da quel che accade mi lascio nuovamente
influenzare e un ciclo è limitato di
avvenimenti di stimoli un ciclo è
limitato di influenze e alla fine siamo
tutti malati
lo confesso il mio obiettivo di oggi è
quello di potervi fare ammalare tutti di
potervi tutti influenzare vi porto un
esempio di una mia recente creazione nei
siciliani riguardo la gestualità siamo
molto generosi anche con un piccolo
come quello di un sopracciglio facciamo
intendere ciò che vogliamo comunicare
noi siciliani latanza l'abbiamo dentro è
innata in noi
così ho approfittato di questa nostra
predisposizione per far venire fuori un
lavoro curioso vi faccio vedere nello
specifico di che cosa sto parlando
la mia coreografia inizia così una piano
prende sempre più campo lo spettatore
siciliano viene coinvolto in prima
persona guardando questi gesti si
rispecchia e niente basta
ok manda avanti velocemente per arrivare
al punto più interessante
lo spettatore si spiano si sente parte
della scena e partecipa fisicamente
mettendo in atto altri gesti interagito
saper fare dopo ulteriori spunti ok
mette un attimo in pausa
questo è un momento importante perché io
da coreografa anziché dietro le quinte
sono in mezzo a voi in mezzo al pubblico
per lasciarmi affascinare dalle vostre
reazioni
io osservo lo spettatore che mi sta
intorno e cerco spunti da poter
catturare e rielaborare e da questa
rielaborazione da questa analisi nascono
nuovi elementi con i quali posso creare
nuovi movimenti e addirittura andare a
rivalutare rimodificare la stessa
coreografia anche più e più volte è una
coreografia in continua rielaborazione
in continua evoluzione è una ricerca di
una componente interiore con stimoli che
provengono dall'esterno
per fare ciò l'improvvisazione diventa
uno strumento indispensabile per la
creazione coreografica una tecnica di
ascolto dell'ambiente e del proprio
corpo
prendo dall'esterno rielaboro dentro me
e creo dei movimenti legati a quello che
nasce e addirittura posso conoscere in
questo modo le molteplici sfaccettature
che posseggo tutti i miei lavori nascono
da questo processo per agevolare
l'acquisizione di stimoli e di
osservazione un elemento utile e
l'empatia
vi invito in questo momento a
immaginarvi come delle antenne e a
lasciarvi influenzare guardandovi
osservandoli dalle persone presenti in
questa sala
da ciò che sta accadendo
sintonizzatevi e osservate catturate e
stimolate il vostro genio creativo
a
[Musica]
[Applauso]
tramite i danzatori bio indotto degli
stimoli in modo più o meno consapevole
avete dato un contributo quando nella
vita
sentita la necessità di motivarvi
anziché ricercare uno stimolo
provate a suscitarlo potreste
sbalordirvi del risultato grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]